keyspace king of space USS Callister so
I have a little bit of a confession this
is the first episode of the black mirror
that I have ever seen black bears been
on my to-do list for a while and it just
long story short it's really hard for me
to find the time to do things that I'm
not also going to do videos of it
because that's just that's how I
maintain the output that I do
it's self-imposed but the amount of free
time you know to watch just whatever is
limited but the new season came out and
normally when a new season of a show
that I've been media chap on comes out
it makes me go uh-huh makes it even less
likely I'm gonna get around to it cuz
now I'm even further behind but black
mirror is an anthology show where every
episodes of self contained things so
it's perfectly fine for me to start with
season four so this was my first one I
have no basis to judge it against any
other episode of black mirror I don't
know if this is good for the show if
this is bad for the show judging it
completely on its own without having
comparisons for what else has been done
on this show I will be talking spoilers
so if that's your warning and I like
this a lot what I really love about it
is it's not just the premise because the
premise is pretty good it's it's all
down to the execution the the layers of
in the way the insidiousness of the
situation creeps in on you because it
opens up with this very cheesy you know
kind of oh bit of a riff on Star Trek
original series okay fine and then you
you meet the character of Daley and
really love Jesse Plemons but I need to
say that now in case I forget to say it
later I love him as an actor I think
he's really great nique and he can do so
much I thought he was good and Breaking
Bad and I loved him in Fargo season 2
and this just this reiterates to me he
is really one of the strongest actors
who's working regularly in television as
opposed to film so anyway you see him in
the real world and you go oh just a
little bit of a
like oh so this is an escape for him
okay these see a little bit of that
darkness here
oh okay so he's kind of taking out his
issues on the the characters in the game
I mean that maybe points to some
psychological damage but I'd suppose
it's a healthy outlet but then that new
girl gets copied and put in and pretty
much as soon as she woke up and was
looking around was like where the hell
am i it started to sink in for me like
well ahead of the explanation from the
other characters of what was going
started to thinking of just oh oh and
realizing the extent of the damage that
this man does and knowing because if
there's any lingering doubt that you
might have that maybe he doesn't fully
appreciate what it is he's done that's
gone when you get the back story on
Walton and his son Timmy which oh crap
man dad oh that was legitimately
monstrous and it's it's it's really just
it's it's it's what I have been told
this show is which is it's existentially
terrifying it's not scary in in terms of
ooh there's a thing creeping around the
corner it's gonna get you know it's
scary in terms of the thoughts it makes
you think but at the same time there's a
lot of really wonderful very funny
moments like I love them just starting
to chat with this big mutant crab
monster thing because you know it's the
girl from marketing oh how you been
or I love that there they're asking
about themselves back in the real world
I'm still the intern really and so
there's a lot of great little funny
moments as well um but it the it doesn't
pull punches when it comes to the
letting it sink in just how horrifying
the core concept of this thing actually
is so that's all really well done and
like I said it's the build it's the
layering and they they got the show got
me to care I was rooting for these
characters that it is flat-out blatant
are not real don't exist they are well
programmed algorithms there ones and
zeros but I cared I cared a lot and the
ending could have been cheesy in terms
of they they get out in there around the
net but it gets away with it largely
because that wasn't their goal like they
didn't know that was gonna happen I love
that their goal was just like we just
wanted to hi we just want to not have to
be here anymore and that really fed into
again sort of the existential dread like
this idea of this horrifying petty God
that you're at the whim of and your only
way out is to die but he won't let you
so if you can find a way to die you win
so like they effectively they won no
matter what so allowing them once they
through the wormhole even if they died I
still would've been like huh so the fact
that they then got out has a bit of a
surprise to them and to me as an
audience member I was like oh that was
nice and they have that little button
moment with the with them just
encountering somebody on the net just
another player and in sort of
acknowledging like you know definite
series the hellish situation but they're
not in a perfect world let's not kid
ourselves about that is the internet and
I kind of like that it it ended on like
just the right note it wasn't so sappy
that it undercut what came before but it
wasn't so cynical as to take away the
triumph of their escaping and their
victory there's almost nothing I don't
kind of love about this I mean there's a
like if I were to nitpick while I do
like the idea of a character basically
blackmailing themselves the whole you
know inappropriate pictures on the cloud
thing I don't it's fine it works as a
narrative device but it also kind of
makes me know and I don't know was there
another way we could have figured out
how to do that or I like the one other
thing I suppose is her like luring him
into the water you know to go swimming
it was a little awkward a little cringy
but if some wasn't that bad because the
the episode played up that like it is
kind of cringy she's desperate and also
there was still tension in the scene
because you're like oh god did she just
overplay it did he just figure out that
something's up so
it still managed to maintain tension
throughout the scene even though I can't
was kind of like Oh are we really going
there but like I said those are like
tiny blips of a miniscule nitpicks this
is I was really kind of blown away by
this
and I I definitely intend to watch the
rest of season 4 I don't know what pace
I'm gonna be able to watch it at but if
I can do it at at anything you know
resembling a decent pace I will do
reviews for the remaining episodes
because you kind of have to deal with
each one in isolation unless you're
doing an overview and giving very short
reviews for each one but honestly this
one at least it was so good it deserves
its own review I wouldn't want to cram
this in with five others and do like two
minutes of pop no this deserve full
recognition I really really was
impressed by this and I'm I'm sure once
I get through this if I like any of the
other episodes as much as I like this
I'm sure I will go back and see earlier
seasons of black mare probably unlikely
that I'll do videos on that because like
I said not topical at all anymore
but yeah I'm I'm glad that I was like
you know what I'm allowed to jump in on
this on season 4 glad I did definitely
dug it
so first episode of season 4 of black
mirror USS Callister have you seen our
hope so talk spoilers actual what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it do all the stuff
likes and subscribes and I got a podcast
and I got a Twitter feed and links for
all that stuff is down below I'm still
taking questions for the Q&A I'm gonna
do once I hit 10,000 subscribers if you
want to take part a night drop a
question here or hit me up on Twitter on
or an email and until next time this
council adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]